bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors c'est un
vin traditionnel exercice ans et de
questions réponses pour un black v ner
poutine sera au rendez vous annuel
comment est ce qu'il est perçu par à la
population russe
c'est une question qu'on pose tout tous
les ans aussi bonjour oui effectivement
c'est un exercice de style qui est
rentré dans la tradition de la
communication présidentielle il est
expliqué qu'en mettant un moyen de faire
remonter l'information de la population
vers le sommet ce qui explique en fait
l'ampleur des questions qu'est-ce qu'on
est en général entre 1 2 million
aujourd'hui de questions adressées sous
des formes diverses et variées c'est
aussi un moyen pour le président de
préciser la position fédérale du
gouvernement sur des grandes questions
de des politiques nationales et
aujourd'hui elles ne manquent pas comme
on l'a vu que ce soit au niveau de la
vaccination obligatoire que ce soit au
niveau de la hausse des prix ou au
niveau de l'ukraine mais c'est aussi un
moyen de régler concrètement certaines
certains problèmes individuels qui se
pose lorsque les pouvoirs locaux sont
défaillants alors je le disais comment
comment la population finalement perçoit
cette rendez vous est ce que c'est pour
les russes un exercice de communication
l'expression d'une de la démocratie
directe
non la démocratie s'exprime par le vote
le pouvoir de décider de quelque chose
en l'occurrence les russes par le fait
de poser une question bon aucun exercice
de démocratie directe c'est un actif
qu'un exercice de communication directe
il essaye de faire régler certains
problèmes quand j'ai dit qu'ils n'ont
pas été réglés il essaie de comprendre
un peu ce qui se passe notamment ceux
qui les intéressent beaucoup et ce qui
inquiète beaucoup aujourd'hui ce qui
était mis en avant c'est la question de
la vaccination obligatoire qui a
beaucoup choqué une partie de la
population et l'on attendait des
réponses assez précise pour l'instant
elle sur cammas et furent alors le
président russe qui appelle tout de même
ses concitoyens à se faire
vacciner sans rendre cela obligatoire et
dans un contexte particulier puisqu'il
ya des recrudescence de cas liés
notamment aux variants indien dans la
dans la capitale comment justement
évoluent là la stratégie centara du
kremlin la stratégie sanitaire du
kremlin justement en reste quelque peu
floue puisque elle semble reposer sur
des stratégies locales comme d'ailleurs
le président l'a expliqué puisque au
niveau fédéral il n'y a pas de
vaccination obligatoire
les députés ayant refusé de voter la
vaccination obligatoire pour le pot vide
mais au niveau local les pouvoirs locaux
peuvent le faire or rappelons que nous
sommes dans le cas d'une pandémie pas
d'une poussée local de rhume quelque
part dans une ville qui pourrait agir
localement donc localement l'on peut
bloquer l'accès aux hôpitaux pour les
personnes non vaccinées pour les soins
courants comme c'est le cas notamment en
secours ce qui va certainement aider à
améliorer la situation sanitaire de la
population
mais à côté de ça on peut au niveau
fédéral ouvrir les frontières pour
développer les vols
donc on aurait aimé avoir quand
effectivement justement cette vision
fédérale de la lutte contre le virus qui
s'annonce être pour de longues années en
tout cas pour une longue période
donc on ne peut pas rester dans une
situation incertaine une situation de
crise pour quelque chose qui deviennent
normalité ou alors il faut dire que
c'est n'est pas une normalité mais dans
ce cas là dans tous les cas il serait
bon quand même qu'un message politique
clair soit passée la stabilité sociale
du pays surtout avant des élections en
septembre
rappelons le les élections
parlementaires est en jeu et on joue
avec le feu et quelque peu dangereux
comme l'histoire l'a déjà montré alors
les élections parlementaires de
septembre
l'avenir poutine va certainement aussi
l'évoquer c'est tout à fait possible
cela dépend des questions qui ont été
posées des questions qui seront retenus
c'est effectivement un moment qui va
être important puisque se pose la
question justement de la régulation au
niveau fédéral de grandes questions
importantes pour le pays et les gens
peuvent être effectivement intéressé de
savoir notamment sur les questions
sanitaires sur les questions de l'école
sur les questions de la gestion des prix
quelles vont être les positions de leurs
représentants après à cette rentrée
alors autre dossier important l'ukraine
le président russe qui affirme que
russes et ukrainiens forme d'un seul
peuple mais il s'interroge tout de même
sur l'utilité d'une rencontre avec son
homologue ukrainien qui selon lui aurait
donné le contrôle de son pays à
l'extérieur pour le citer alain ce
qu'est un dialogue direct vous semble
exclue dans un avenir proche
la rencontre entre bayonne et poutine a
montré que rien n'est jamais à exclure
donc d'ailleurs le président russe n'a
pas exclu a priori une rencontre à
exigence qui il a à juste titre soulevé
la question de l'intérêt de cette
rencontre puisque pourquoi discuter avec
quelqu'un qui finalement et n'a pas la
maîtrise le contrôle politique de son
pays
c'est comme parler avec un facteur et
non pas avec la personne qui nous en vol
pourrait en quelque sorte
donc effectivement c'est une question
qui peut être envisagée en compte qui
peut être envisagée mais très justement
l'enjeu était posée et pour en faire
quoi
alors il ya d'autres sujets notamment
internationaux sur la table peut-être
les dossiers comme le nucléaire iranien
également là à quoi s'attendre ça va
être aussi important lors de ce marathon
ce sont des questions qui pour la
population reste oublions pas que ce ne
sont pas les questions qui sont posées
par des journalistes ce sont des
questions qui sont posées par les gens
et je ne suis pas certaine que dans la
situation actuelle où il y a un problème
changes dont une baisse de revenus qui
ont des problèmes d'accès à l'emploi qui
sont confrontés à une hausse des prix
soit particulièrement perturbé par la
question du nucléaire iranien
la question peut être amené sur la table
parce que politiquement et effectivement
au niveau du positionnement de la russie
sur la scène internationale elle est
importante mais elle est importante pour
la russie en tant que pays je ne suis
pas sûr qu'elle a une incidence directe
sur la vie des gens actuellement c'est
donc à un jeu de questions réponses plus
axé évidemment sur des questions de
politique intérieure et sociales
également merci à vous karine béchir
gologo professeur invité à l'université
d'état de moscou